i did research uh on the orcas because i
wanted to
i'm i'm a trainer so i needed to know
about uh
this magnificent animal so that was the
biggest part of my research
because i started to watch
videos of
amputated people
and
and i realized very quickly that i
didn't need it
because it's just happened in her life
and um
and that's what i felt right away i mean
it would have been different if my
character had been in this situation for
10 years for example i would have
researched a lot
but
because it's so fresh
i i thought i would
experience with her i mean thanks god i
will never experience that
we touch wood in france yes
i hit the boxing gym
on a daily basis for a couple of months
and um i ate haagen-dazs for uh
a couple months on a daily basis
pasta you know no jacques wanted me to
grow a little belly because he wanted me
to look strong but not fit
um so yeah that was quite it was kind of
intense yeah yes we used a collection of
short story
from craig davidson who is an
anglo-canadian writer
after um a previous film a prophet that
was set in jail and it was just with men
there was no light no space.
a love story with a strong female
character and
space and light
davidson
and so uh
jack read the short stories of craig
davidson and then he kind of piled up
his desire to make a um
to tell a love story upon the short
stories because if i may add there is no
love story in the short stories of craig
davidson there is no female character
the writer is speaking
and so we had that idea of making a love
story and that we had to pile it up on
on on the the short stories of craig
davidson because what we got from the
short stories was the whales that a lot
of things that we would not have been
able to uh imagine ourselves
jacques likes to treat his screenplay as
as living matter and then he wants the
screenplay to start living on set
so he hopes that the scenes that we we
do on set
take a different turn than he originally
planned in the screenplay and when i was
about to read the script i i expected
something very special because all his
films
are
very special
and uh and the story he tells but what i
didn't expect was to read a love story
and it would it was even more excited
exciting
and
and well then i fell in love with the
character the characters all of them
and this is very
hard to explain
why you fall in love
yeah
come on you see my question i know when
i started making films
on my first feature i had everything set
up and i knew exactly where i was
i used to handle him like that and told
me don't touch me anymore
no i don't prepare anything and i just
wait for it to come
the day before you go oh maybe the scene
should be this or that and then we we
should go at it in this way or that way
and then once you get on set it turns
out to be uh something totally different
and that's what's interesting about it
because then it's
it's it's vivid it's it's alive it's not
just just an execution of what you
thought of my first reading i told jack
well i
i don't really know who she is and i i
was kind of worried that he would recap
that that the actress who wanted to play
the role didn't really know who the
character
was after the first reading but
but he told me well neither do i we're
gonna have to
meet her you know
and it was very interesting because
we realized at a certain at a certain
point that
this mystery was part of her
and that we didn't have to solve all the
mystery both characters are ambiguous
they have their flaws their they have
their qualities
and that's what makes them so beautiful
and so it's not about being the most
likable um it's just about making this
love story as powerful as possible